desde que comenzó la ofensiva en el
donbas especialmente por esas ciudades
de severodonés kilis y chans en mayo y
junio cientos de miles de personas han
abandonado esta región del este de
Ucrania y en los últimos meses
especialmente de esas poblaciones de
bacmut o soledad donde se centran
actualmente las batallas muchas de esas
familias
han ido camino a otros lugares de
Ucrania sin embargo otras por diferentes
motivos han decidido quedarse en deni
pro que es la primera ciudad importante
que encuentran a la salida del donbas y
este por ejemplo es un ejemplo de cómo
conviven muchas de esas familias
especialmente mujeres con niños que han
abandonado esta región sola ya porque
sus maridos sean combatientes de las
fuerzas ucranianas o porque en el caso
de las mujeres mayores los hombres ya
con una edad decidieron Incluso en
territorio controlado por Rusia cuidando
aquellas casas que es su único
patrimonio en este lugar donde nos
encontramos conviven actualmente 30
familias 90 personas pero aquí acogen
todos los días a familias que son
evacuadas desde esta región de Ucrania y
que o deciden por ejemplo alquilar sus
propios apartamentos o irse a otras
regiones o a otros lugares de Europa
aquí nos cuentan algunas de las mujeres
que los niños tienen apoyo psicológico
también reciben sus clases siguen
estudiando y todo esto que vemos
equipado está ayudado por ayuda de la
cooperación europea muchos tienen la
esperanza o la mayoría aquí de que la
situación pueda controlarse en un futuro
que sus poblaciones que están en control
de las fuerzas rusas vuelvan a ser
retomadas por Ucrania y puedan volver a
sus casas Aunque saben que muchas de
ellas están destruidas